Tory starts off this hour in Huntsville
Alabama hi Tory how are you hey what an
honor it is to speak with you sir
you too what's up well I'll try make
this as quick as possible my life for
about a year and a half from paying our
house all Phoebe please hit free so
we've had three major life things had
hit us all at one time the one I want to
talk to you about is before we bought
the home we bought it in August we'll be
two years ago I hired an inspector a
little bit that I do have a real estate
license before I bought the home I got
my real estate license to save the 3%
and I've sold several homes actually
since then too
but I did get an inspector recently I
discovered a foundation issue so and
I've had three professionals to
structural gap in one Mason and they've
all said that you know there's no way
this wasn't fair you know when the
inspector came out so I've reached out
to him he hung up he hung up on me
um you know I know you're a real estate
guy so I just wanted to get your take I
want you to he hung up on you
he did no how did that conversation
sound like well I just said you know hey
you know I've had the inspectors come
out they said that this clearly you know
was here he tried to find pictures he
couldn't find any
he sent me something that even the
pictures that he said didn't line up
with what he was trying to say so I
called him and I said you know this
isn't making sense and he basically said
well it sounds like you told me and
Chris conversations over and he hung up
on me okay
um and I do have that conversation
recorded I don't know if that helps or
not yeah I doubt it the so what's it
going to take to fix the house you know
um I've got several estimates ranging
anywhere from around 6,000 to around
17,000 okay and why did it take you two
years to find it if he should have found
it I um I was actually we did a total
remodel on the house and did most of the
work or so I built in shutters and I was
out there putting them on and I saw a
gap between the brick and the window and
then I
or something obviously is weird here and
I called him out to look at it and he
came out and he said oh you know this is
just a cause from the event in my
crawlspace
he said that's what causes it and it was
a simple $200 fix so you know and then I
started getting the inspectors come out
and it turns out become totally
different how does a vent in your crawl
space cause the brick to supper in the
window exactly
unless the vent collapsed or something
yep which is then mr. starts tracking
brickwork clearly you know the block in
the footer on the northeast side of the
home you know they'll sorry how big a
hole is this um but you know it's not
actually that bad with there's just some
cracks in the block with footer is and
that's business in that one isolated
spot there is some cracks in the brick
on the other side of the house um do you
have any reason to think the house are
still moving well um I don't know I've
been told you can mark it and you can
see if it yeah keeps moving yeah I would
do that I I you know from our just a
practical standpoint most houses settle
in our in our area of the country
Alabama Tennessee as a matter of fact I
just had some settlement cracks fixed on
a house I built four years ago and it
busted loose a balcony in it it pops
some drywall it just moved a little and
they just move sometimes a little bit
and it's hard to get one that doesn't
ever have any kind of a crack so a
little bit of tuck point on that is not
unusual you know it doesn't like you got
a structural breakdown so you got some
brick that are pulling apart and I don't
know it just sounds like it's a fairly
small hole I'm probably going to tuck
point that with some mortar and go not
to try to hide it from a potential buyer
but I mean I would disclose it but just
go hey there's some settlement over here
and so forth I got some concrete
driveway at my house my personal home
right now that's moved over seven years
and I'm probably going to take some of
that out but it's just a we built that
house and it's settled some and I've
tucked pointed that stuff I don't know
if it's going to work or not but it's
going to it may end up moving more but
it still seems to be on the slide but
side point anyway I'm not tucked point
that and probably move on meaning a
little bit of mortar in
those cracks and try to match it as
close as I can if it keeps moving then
we've got a deal with it and come back
but I don't I don't hear anything
structurally wrong with this house like
it's about to fall in with the way
you're describing it I'm not an engineer
okay and I'm I'm a talk radio guy on the
other end of a telephone having a too
many conversation about your house so if
you're more concerned about it than that
that's there I you know I think the guy
probably missed it most if I were an
inspector one of the things I'm always
going to look for settlement cracks
instead just to point them out but I
also would probably minimize the risk
around them if I were I wouldn't tell
you to not buy that house because it had
a you know half-inch cracker inch crack
around something unless it's still
moving and you got a sinkhole problems
or something like that but again I own a
bunch of property and I got this on a
lot of them it's not that unusual so
imagine you're seeing this yeah yeah a
bunch so I mean I'm it doesn't panic me
but again that's kind of crosses that
line at some point where the things
freakin falling down now we got a you
know I'm going to do some foundation
work and now you got a $10,000 event and
that kind of a thing so if you think
that that's where you are then I guess
you probably need to see an attorney and
see if this inspector has some errors
and omissions insurance because he
missed this and he's just not man enough
to go hey I missed the crack okay
instead he tried trying to talk it up
like it's nothing and try and talk it
down like you want to worry about it
like man I didn't see it I missed it but
also don't think it's a $17,000 fix so I
thought that was a little bit ridiculous
also I just didn't matter of fact the
guy that gave me that quote he said if
it were me and it was my home I would
just watch it yeah because if I put the
piercing that's going to be about seven
feet yeah I took pointed and watch it's
what I would do and that that's a one
bag of mortar it's not a big expensive
thing it's a lot less than a lawsuit
because Bubba is obviously not going to
own up to his work he's walked back
which by the way in a town the size of
Huntsville and you being a real estate
agent was a really dumb thing to do he
had a lot of rear so he a lot of reasons
are making hasslein bar excellent my
broker about it yesterday but down here
he said you know what we took him off
our vendor list six month
for this very issue so he just lost 40
agents yet and and you know and so and
it doesn't stop there because you know
you'll be talking to somebody else in
the business and it's just not that big
a town so he's putting himself out of
business but business isn't hard you
just got to do the right thing and
people that don't do the right thing
capitalism kind of purchases it kind of
takes care of them and word-of-mouth
does that so that yeah I'm thinking
that's probably what I'm doing if I'm in
your shoes
but a good question man interesting
situation sorry you're facing that and
been through all the drama but I'm
probably like your guy said I'm gonna
talk point that and watch it and then
we'll back up and see what we got to do
from there with the next moves are open
phones now see I turn into a house
repair guy but I've done so many rehab
Johnny I've owned over a thousand pieces
of property in my life and I rehabbed
hundreds and hundreds of properties and
you know run crews on that and I still
own a bunch of property we still do a
lot of maintenance on a lot of different
kinds of properties and you know you
just learn about it in the process it's
not like I'm an expert in engineering or
construction or something like that but
it's like termites you know termites
don't scare me anymore you know we kill
them if we find them but you know the
hope we don't just melt down and die in
the floor because they saw a termite
they're everywhere in the south you just
kill them this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better
Dave Ramsey channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you